-Welcome to the show.
-Thank you so much.
It's great to be here.
-You are very busy right now.
Running for governor
takes a lot of time and effort.
-I am. I was in six different
cities just this weekend.
-That is a crazy thing to do.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-It's a big state.
-Yeah, I would say if you ever
told anybody
you were in six cities
in one weekend,
they would just assume
you were running for governor.
There's really no other reason
to do that.
-Or a stand-up comedian.
-Or a stand-up -- that's true.
-One or the other.
-So, one of things you and your
opponent, Governor Cuomo,
are trying to frame yourself as
is the person who will most
take on Donald Trump.
-Right.
-He obviously has history of
Donald Trump
being a New Yorker like he is.
You have a little history with
Donald Trump as well.
When you won an Emmy,
Donald Trump gave you your Emmy.
[ Laughter ]
-I look very pained, don't I?
-Yeah. It does. You seem very --
-I look so happy
to be receiving an Emmy
but just wish it was
from someone else.
-Yeah.
And your other option
was Simon Cowell. You know?
-But you see how Donald
actually doesn't want to let go
of the Emmy?
-Yeah.
-Because, you know, he was
nominated so many times.
And he never had one of his own,
and in retrospect,
I think that maybe if I had just
let him have mine,
we wouldn't be in the situation
that we're in.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yes. We can all look back.
We can all look back.
-But hindsight is always 20/20.
-It does look like he is saying
to you like,
"So I think this is
something we share.
I'll get it on weekends."
You know?
So, one of the things you've
been talking a lot about
in your campaign so far is the
influence of money in politics.
-Yes.
-Obviously, this is something
that happens nationally.
This is something
that happens locally.
that happens at the state level.
How do you go about
getting money out of politics?
How do you go about getting
this message across to voters?
-Right.
So, I think that obviously
the influence of big money,
the influence of corporations
in politics is nothing new,
but I think
we've arrived at a moment
where corporations have so much
power and so much money,
and they're spending it
so plentifully on our electeds
that there is almost no daylight
between the corporate agenda
and New York state policy
at the moment.
And it's, you know,
it's no coincidence
that Andrew Cuomo's --
one of the industries
that donates the most to him
is real estate,
and we're having a tremendous
housing affordability crisis
across the state.
I think these two facts are
very, very linked,
and I think it's really
important that, for example,
in my campaign
I'm not accepting a single dime
of corporate contributions.
Right?
-And have you found --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So that -- so that when I --
when I get to Albany,
I won't be beholden
to my corporate donors
because I won't have any.
-That's a very easy solution to
the problem
of how to not be beholden.
-It is. It is.
-You -- A lot of people are
giving you credit for,
even before the election,
pulling the governor
to the left on certain issues.
You have brought up issues,
things like single payer.
You mention affordable housing.
You talk about --
-Whole host of
environmental issues
we've got him to move
to the left on.
-You got him to the left.
"The New York Times" just wrote
an endorsement, and obviously,
they had to pick a candidate.
They gave you a lot of credit
in this piece for the issues
that you were pulling
the governor to the left on.
They also said
that he had brought
a degree of corruption
to Albany,
and yet in the end
they endorsed him
despite making all these points
because he would be more likely
to be able to implement things
due to his experience.
What was it like reading that?
-Well, they effectively said,
right, we have a governor
whose administration has been
rife with corruption,
and if anything,
the last four years,
his administration
has outdone itself.
They listed all the things that
he hasn't accomplished,
and they effectively said,
"We have an incredibly
dysfunctional, corrupt
Cuomo administration.
But he's our Andrew Cuomo
and we think the next four years
are gonna be entirely different.
Let's endorse him."
-That might -- I mean, because
as you read it, it seemed like
they were gonna definitely
endorse you,
and then at the end they didn't.
Were you like, "Wow, that was
a real twist at the end there"?
[ Laughter ]
-You know, this is -- this is
an insurgent campaign.
This is
a people-powered campaign,
and I think that so many people
in the establishment
are not grasping the moment that
we're in and are not grasping --
with Donald Trump
in the White House,
it's a really terrible moment
for our country.
But I think what voters are
trying to say
to the Democratic establishment
and are saying it in volumes
when you look at the victory --
Ayanna Pressley last night
in Massachusetts.
If you look at Andrew Gillum
last week in Florida,
these are --
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.
These are people
who were not predicted to win,
who were down by 30 points
in some cases,
and have marched on to victory
because voters understand
something the Democratic Party
leadership doesn't seem to,
which is that with Donald Trump
in the White House,
we actually have not only
a possibility
but we have an obligation
to elect leaders
who will bring
real progressive change,
whether you're talking about
single payer healthcare,
universal rent regulation,
whether you're talking about
New York becoming a leader
in renewable energy.
We have to elect more Democrats
this year,
but we also have to
elect better Democrats.